Memorial Day in Israel is a day
when people across the country
gather and remember those
who were killed in the
military, typically in conflict.
Ludmila Rozhkov's son German Rozhkov
was killed in March of 2002.
When someone is killed in the army,
a delegation is given the
very solemn and difficult task
of going to the family and
telling them what has happened.
They arrived at Ludmila's apartment,
and she tried to block the door
in the hope of blocking the truth.
She was just beside herself with grief.
And at a certain point, she said,
"we must get German's sperm."
In Israel there is a growing practice
of post-mortem sperm retrieval,
in which, if a man dies in the military,
his family can ask the
military to retrieve sperm
from his corpse and to freeze
it to create a future child.
The sperm in his testicles
continue to survive
for certainly 24 hours and,
indeed, possibly up to 72.
A skilled doctor can remove
sperm cells from his testicle
and put them on ice, and it
can then sit for decades.
And through in vitro
fertilization create a child.
It is banned in a number of
countries, but in Israel,
which has an enormous embrace of pro natal
and fertility policies
in order to build a strong population,
it is in fact, increasingly common.
People who die in car accidents,
of cancer and so forth,
their families have asked to use it.
We're not talking about huge numbers
but in Israel the focus
right now is on young men
who die in the military.
Sperm extraction is actually something
that we've been doing for
as long as I remember.
But in the last years, it
became more and more frequent.
I'm on call 24/7, and
sometimes I get a phone call
in the middle of the night.
I watch TV and I see some breaking news
of some terrorist attack
in Tel Aviv or nearby.
I tell myself, okay, sure
enough they will call me.
These relatives are in deep grief.
They've just been notified that
their loved one was killed.
Within a few hours, they can
get an approval from a judge
for us to perform this procedure.
There is like a glimpse of hope
and maybe a little bit of light.
There is a lot of responsibility
because you are helping
to create a child who is
an orphan to begin with.
Post-mortem sperm retrieval
has been more common
when the man is married,
but really what is so striking
about the situation in Israel
is many people feel, "I
want to be a grandparent.
This is an important stage
of life that I deserve.
And if the state has
asked my son for service
and he dies in that service,
it owes me this help in
becoming a grandparent."
It is now relatively common,
should a young man die
in the military, for
the parents to be aware
that they can ask for this.
And then the military
will pay for the procedure
as with Ludmila Rozhkov who
said, "I have lost my only son.
I want a grandchild."
And the court acknowledged
and agreed to that.
In many ways, Ludmila was a pioneer
who brought this to Israel.
And interestingly, she's
not a native-born Israeli.
She comes from Crimea.
Ludmila took a long time
to decide how to proceed.
It was about a dozen years after.
And then it took four
years of a court battle
for them to get permission
to use the sperm,
and the judge that they faced
quoted from the Hebrew Bible
saying "pru u'rvu", "be
fruitful and multiply"
but complications arose
in the court cases,
because of the question of who
is in charge of this sperm.
This is not the same thing
as giving your kidney or your eye.
This is creating another human being.
The Supreme Court made a
ruling based not on the Bible
but on what case law existed,
a decision which said
there is no such thing as
a right to grandparenthood.
We cannot grant this sperm to
someone other than the widow,
and essentially sent a
message to the Knesset,
to the parliament that said,
if you want this thing to
move forward, we need a law.
There are people creating a law,
which will ask every young man,
when he is inducted into the
military at the age of 18,
whether he has something he
would like done with his sperm,
should he die in uniform.
There is an incredible focus
on the family in Israel
and on having babies.
So Israel has, from the very
beginning, viewed its role
as a place to rebuild
the Jewish nation. Why?
It comes, of course, just a few years
after the Nazi Holocaust,
in which 6 million Jews were slaughtered.
So even though there's a fairly
heavy religious component
in Israel, the fact is
there is a secular drive
to have children in a
way that is incomparable
in the rest of the wealthy world.
We combine this with the
exceptional place of the military
in Israeli society, where
essentially everyone puts in
for boys three years for
girls a little under two years
of military service.
So everyone is linked to this institution.
And when someone dies serving his country,
the desire to honor that
person is also very pronounced.
And so parents go onto Facebook
or they get interviewed on
television and they say,
"My son died in the
service of this country,
and we're looking for a woman
to bear and raise his child."
And what is remarkable is that hundreds,
indeed thousands of
women raise their hands
and volunteer to be that mother.
Baruch Ben Ygal has been very involved
with the Zvi Hauser law and others,
because since the Supreme Court said,
"We need to really have evidence
that this young man wanted children,"
he said, "I want to put all
my energy into creating a law
instead of trying to go
through the court system."
Although he said, "I am certain
that he very much wanted to be a father."
And he said to me, he has a
book of 5,000 names of women
who want to be the mother
of his future grandchild.
Broadly, Israel very much
embraces this process,
but there are dissenters.
There are deep worries, ethical and legal.
People are saying, "I don't understand
why would you do this on purpose?
You are condemning this child
to being a kind of living monument
as opposed to having a
relatively normal life.
Life is hard enough."
So Baruch is very involved
in lobbying for this law
and he is politically savvy and connected.
So he's used those
connections for this cause.
But he's not alone.
There is a nonprofit
organization advocating for this
in getting everybody on board.
There obviously is hesitation
of the defense ministry
and others to institutionalize
something like this,
but it looks like it has the
wind at its back right now.
So, when you first hear
about this procedure,
it's hard not to feel a
little bit freaked out.
At the same time, when
you meet these families
and the fervor and love that
they bring to this fight,
you melt, because you see
that what is it that
drives us in life is love.
And these people are engaged
in a fight for familial love.
And that's a very powerful force.